all right guys
bang bang i've got will here just him
and i
back like usual uh will what's going on
man how are you
hey i'm doing well paul i'm excited for
it to just be back like old times i feel
like it has been the two of us in
forever
i know but yeah you know it's been a
it's been an interesting week uh
you know excited to get into it but uh
doing well otherwise about yourself
i i think people have really enjoyed the
conversations we've been having with
other folks but uh there's a couple
people who just miss
you and i going through the through the
data so maybe let's just start with uh
kind of this rsi indicator normally uh
you are not known for putting technical
analysis into
the newsletter but you included rsi uh
as kind of the first metric this week
explain kind of what that is and why
you're looking at it
yeah sure so like for anybody who does
ta rsi is just you know
a relatively basic indicator it's
basically kind of tracking the strength
of price
and so you have this range right and
oscillator oscillates through that range
when it gets above it's considered
overbought when it goes below
it's considered oversold and so when you
look at this rsi on the dailies time
frame and you kind of zoom out
you can see that we've been in this kind
of downward trend since um
kind of the beginning of of uh january
and
we're right now kind of retesting that
that trend line um we've tested it and
it served as resistance eight times
um at the time that i wrote this we were
at like
250 dollars higher than we were so we
were actually starting to break out
above
um but you need uh you need a
confirmation on the daily close to
determine if you have broken out or not
so i don't know just just something to
keep an eye on
um you know it looks like we're kind of
coiling up some momentum and price there
um and that also kind of correlates with
uh volatility which which we've been
tracking
um any kind of major you know indication
of volatility is showing that we're
ready for a big move
um you can look at like bollinger bands
or you can also just look at like the
historical volatility index and then
just kind of plot that out and you'll
see once again that we're kind of at
this
um trend resistance line um you know
downward sloping trend line where you
know bitcoin looks ready to break out
and you know the volatility doesn't
necessarily mean that the move is going
to be up
it just means that we're going to have a
big move right but um looking at these
you know some of these other things i
think you can get you know a better
indication as to
where that big move is perhaps going
which i think a lot of people know where
i kind of stand in that so and the next
thing you looked at was the perpetual
funding rate so explain what this is and
kind of what it's telling you right now
yeah sure so uh the perp funding rate is
unique to bitcoin where
the the perp is essentially um you know
this futures contract that doesn't
expire you can think of it that way and
it's a contract
that's pegged to bitcoin price and so
it's pegged to it through the funding
rate
and so uh for the derivatives
they have something called an index and
it's basically like a weighted average
price
based off of all the major exchanges um
and so
to to keep the contract pegged to
bitcoin price
um the funding rate adjusts in
correlation to
um what what the perp is trading at in
uh
relative to to that index so
when the perp is trading at a premium to
spot it the the funding rate is positive
versus when uh it's trading at a
discount to spot
you have negative funding rates um so
prolonged funding rates to that are
negative that are negative
are bullish prolonged funding rates that
are positive
are bearish um and what we've had is is
prolonged funding rates since late may
um a couple days here and they're
positive but overall negative
um and so the last time that we've had
prolonged funding rates like this
was after the march 2020 crash and kind
of in that that uh
you know re-accumulation phase after
that um
you know it's it's been pretty much
completely positive
throughout the you know whole main phase
of the the bull market up until may so
um you know it's been good to see these
negative funding rates but especially
over the last uh you know
24 48 hours as we've started rally a
little bit
what that's basically showing is that um
you know the the spot
the the rally is more driven by spot
than the derivatives
so if if if the futures were at a
premium
like i would i would be a little more
short short term
skeptical because all these traders are
coming in and leverage longing um to
move up
versus what seems like to be going on
now is spot is actually leading the
price up
while it looks like sentiment from from
traders is bearish
which is you know by definition like
denial in the market right you
you want to see uh disbelief of the
rally for us to be able to move up
higher
um it's almost like when we're at a top
a top is when like the biggest bears
turn bullish and
everyone just thinks we're going
straight up so the con the consensus is
that we're going higher and so
you know traders are are super uh
bullish and that kind of gives incentive
for price to be pushed the other
direction um we have the same thing so
like
we had a long squeeze on the way down
where everyone was long and then
um you know you it didn't take as much
selling pressure to
as it would have otherwise if you didn't
have this high leverage to the
position for more upside to push the
price down and it's the same kind of
thing here so like
you know when we dip down below 30k
people were loading on shorts
um and you know even since we rallied
out of there it still seems like traders
aren't
respecting the pump so to say um which
is what you what you want to see to kind
of have this disbelief rally and slow
grind up out of the bottom
so um watching those funding rates uh
pretty closely like every hour um just
it just to see kind of how traders are
reacting to the market
got it and then we've got this liquid
supply ratio that you highlighted as
well
yeah um liquid supply has been one of my
favorite charts over the last month
um it's one of the one of the trips that
like willie helped me create
it's basically comparing a liquid supply
to liquid and highly liquid supply and
so you're essentially capturing this
movement
of coins from from weak hands um
to to strong hands and so i literally
labeled the chart bitcoins moving to
strong hands
but yeah it's it's a liquid supply ratio
and so
what you've seen is throughout the early
um throughout the kind of
middle part of the bull run i should say
well you know um
like late late september to early to to
mid april
you saw this really strong increase in
this and so that was showing a bunch of
coins were getting locked up
um you know we had that supply shock
right and so
you could also look at exchange flows to
see that as well but when we got
into mid-may late may um you all of a
sudden started to see this
oscillator trend down if i had this back
then then i probably would have been
less polished than i was at the time uh
because you just started seeing a bunch
of coins that that were
being puked out by what was previously
recognized as strong hands
uh and so since late may you've seen
this kind of slow grind up in this
but then over the last couple weeks a
big a big pop big move up and so that to
me is indicating
um yeah we've had slow reaccumulation
but over the last couple weeks that's
ramped up and we're starting to see more
aggressive accumulation
and of course you know that that's been
trending up while price has been slowly
grinding down so
um you know we've been talking about on
the show this this
divergence between this and price um i
personally
haven't seen any divergence larger than
this i asked willie if he has and he
says that he can't think of anything
um the only other divergence i've seen
and somewhat recently that that
represents
that uh represents us is in late
september
after we had that big drop um i remember
like when we
when we first you know started going
into the bull run um we kind of had that
that move up and then that
sideways bart if you look on the chart
you'll you'll see that
um after that after that dump it was a
similar kind of
idea but just on a smaller magnitude
where like a bunch of coins became
liquid
and then you saw this up like slow grind
up in this in this
indicator which was showing like those
coins were getting reaccumulated
but price was continuing to trend down
so like you had the similar divergence
there but just not on you know such a
large magnitude so
the way i kind of see this is like the
larger the divergence the bigger effect
it's going to have on price
um and and so i suspect that once we
kind of
um start to get volume back because i
think that's part of the reason why
you haven't seen this like this
information priced into the market yet
is because we've been having very very
low volume
but i suspect once you start to get
full-blown volume back
and you know i think that's likely to
come soon because we were talking about
you know volatility breaking out
um i think once that volume comes back
in then you'll see this
supply shock really start to get priced
in because as of right now
um when you look at the ratio and then
you look at where we were earlier this
year
we're at levels that we were at at about
50 to 60 k btc
hey guys what's going on before we
continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
got it and when you think about this otc
outflow rsi i think this is an indicator
that you created
um is that kind of confirming exactly
what you're seeing with the
uh with the supply ratios and kind of
this movement
to strong hands yeah
very similar so you know people talk
about exchange flows you can also look
at um
otc flows and so kind of like from a
first principle standpoint
i was thinking you know what's the money
that moves the market it's whales right
it's institutions high net worth
individuals
so how can you track that and so um
i think one of the one of the best ways
to look at this is just looking at you
know the raw flows in and out of otc
desks which is where you know these
these entities navigate through to make
their purchases or sell
um and so i kind of plotted this out
with with an rsi
and then you can kind of gauge these
really strong
um moves up in in outflows
so if there's a really strong trend in
outflows the indicator will break out of
the rsi range
and then you'll get what i label as a
buy indicator and then
if there's a there's a lack of otc
outflows right if there's very low
demand
then the the strength of the indicator
of the oscillator
will trend below the range and then
that's considered a cell because there's
very low demand right
and so this has had pretty um accurate
signals over the last year
but we actually just flashed the second
in a row um second uh
buy signal but the reason why i think
this one has so much weight is because
it's the largest that we've seen since
last july
so like if you look at this in the
newsletter or you can plot this out
yourself for anybody on glass node
um you can see that that this rsi this
this
outflow rsi is really ripped up um
and even stronger than it was last july
but uh you know
it's on par with with the levels that
it's at but really aggressive move up in
that
and so to me looking at that along with
seeing whale wallets pick up
you know you've seen them accumulate uh
pretty heavily over the last few weeks
those two things are kind of coinciding
with each other and saying the same
thing
um and then below that i just i just put
out a chart of comparing the outflows to
the inflows
and then you'll see that right now that
the outflows are outweighing the inflows
to
otc desks yeah and what's fascinating to
me about the outflow to inflow
is uh it's very clear that this is not
just
kind of a uh you know one day thing this
has been a trend here for a little bit
um since uh since maybe like mid-july or
so now
in the past and i know this is just kind
of you speculating versus
uh actually being able to prove any of
this it appears that the inflow outflow
chart kind of uh
it rises it peaks it kind of comes back
down it rises it peaks
what drives uh kind of its inability to
just go parabolic right and kind of take
off like that is that just
uh natural cyclical you know parts of
the market is that that there's just
only so much bitcoin that people can buy
any ideas there
yeah i think you see you know like
bigger spikes
in in um the otc in and out flows both
um you know so basically like otc volume
if you will
um when you kind of get to these bigger
inflection points
like you know when we originally dumped
down in late may
you saw you know a big spike in those in
and out flows um but you know as long as
they're matching each other then it
neutralizes it out so
um i think like when you see a strong
move up
and you see um you know those those
those outflows or inflows for that
matter for you know if you're
trying to make a bear case if you see
those strongly you know
outpacing the other then i think that's
that's a stronger signal and also if
you're getting
uh multiple in a row so like you know
right now we if you look at the chart
we've had
five straight um you know kind of
coinciding spikes between in and out
flows where
outflows have have outpaced uh inflows
and so
to me that that makes that that gives it
a more bullish signal and you're also
seeing if you look at the two
you know this like higher high in in the
indian outflows both respectively
so it's showing that there's more
activity going on right and then
if you look back in late may you had
four straight
um bearish spikes where where uh inflows
were outpacing
um the outflow so that that that would
you know obviously resemble
more of a bearish signature got it and
then when you overlaid all of these
uh various charts on top of each other
looking at the various wallet cohorts
uh it appears that again just kind of
confirmation that uh
whales are absolutely buying up uh
bitcoin
kind of adding what is 110 000 bitcoin
to uh they're holding since may 19th
yeah exactly so this is just comparing
the holdings of different sized entities
like you said
um i couldn't fit everyone in here that
would have wanted to so i kind of just
grabbed some of the vane ones uh because
i can only
compare four charts to the time and
glass node but i compared
what's essentially retail uh and then
you're looking at uh the octopus and
shrimp
um dolphins and sharks and then the
whales so
you know these are retail which is below
one btc
um 100k to 1k btc
uh 10 10 to 100 btc and then 1000 to 10k
btc
and so what you see is almost every
major cohort is in accumulation
um you know the retail has been stacking
harder than ever i don't know if
going back in the chart that i've ever
seen them add to their positions this
heavily
they've added over 37 000 btc since that
may 19th capitulation event
whales are accumulating like i said
especially over the last few weeks
they've now added over 110 000 like you
said since uh
since the may 19th capitulation
100 to a thousand btc this is an
interesting cohort because
that this has been trending up
aggressively throughout the year
um i suspect this kind of resembles like
hedge funds or or high net worth
individuals just given the sizing
and kind of coinciding spikes that you
saw between this cohort's holdings
and um the the cash and carry uh you
know the
spreads there but you saw a huge
increase kind of at the beginning of the
year in this cohort and then this should
actually kind of just like bled
sideways which has been interesting um
just given like how aggressively they
had been adding to their holdings and
now that just seems to have completely
stopped
but then again the whales are
accumulating so um
you know i it can get a little noisy
like trying to
compare each major cohort like if i
would if i was able to break it down
i would i would probably just do like
you know retail
everything below one and then kind of
look at the mid-size holders rate and
then
anything over a thousand is really a
whale in my opinion um
and so willie's actually done some um
kind of his own variant of this work
he's looked at you know
uh the exchange holdings that are that
are shown as entities between
um you know over over 10 000 because the
reason i didn't include 10 to 100 000 is
some of those
some of that some of that is and uh some
of that is exchanges so like if that's
going up that's not necessarily fully
bullish because it could
it could just be an exchange that's
recognized as an entity with with
that amount of btc between 10 and 100
000 as their balance going up right so
willie actually filtered some of those
things out and he put together a little
thread on twitter so i would highly
suggest people go check that out but
um you just keep that in mind so like
for example like the over 100 000 btc
cohort
um you know a lot of people will be like
oh the you know the massive whales are
dumping the over 100 000
um you know entities are dumping like
guys these are exchanges
that that's a bullish thing the
exchanges are there their supplies going
down so like
you you have to you have to look at what
are what are these cohorts and like
um kind of factor out some of these
things like in the over 100k
entities um you know once you once you
factor out exchanges and then you factor
out great scale
you're left with 150 000 btc and so
by definition there can only be one it
can only be one
other entity other than exchanges in
grayscale so
just this concept of like and i suspect
that's likely some kind of like
custodial service that um
that that last entity but anyway i just
think like
you need to look at what what are the
other entities that are that fall under
those
um kind of cohorts to be able to get the
best picture and willie kind of
subtracted those out and got a more
accurate signal but
um yeah just for anybody that perhaps
like i i've got a few comments that were
saying
look at look at the 10 to 100k btc
cohort and also the the over 100 case i
just wanted to just clear that up
yep that makes sense and then it seems
like a lot of the selling is coming from
the younger market participants which
has been a theme that we've been talking
about now for a couple of weeks but but
what do you see in there
yeah sure so this is something that's
been turning down since um
january and for a while in the
newsletter i have been throwing in
um dormancy which is like a variant of
coin days destroyed
and so the way you can think of that is
you know while uh coins in a wallet for
one day coin moves out of the wallet one
coin day is destroyed right and and so
this is a this is a good signal in a
bull market to kind of gauge
um the selling of older mark
participants when you have higher
coin days destroyed then that's showing
that um you know older coins are being
sold
we can also just show that there's um
really high volume so for example like
you could have one coin that has you
know 10
coin days that's sold and and that shows
up as 10 coin days destroyed or you
could have
um 10 coins that have been sitting in a
wallet for one day
and you still get the same amount of
coin days destroyed so
i think here you need to look at um
some something that is is going to be um
not not um adjusted for that for that
volume that
once my bad something that is adjusted
for that volume which is the the a
sole not not the uh not the coin days
destroyed because this is just literally
the raw average
of the age of the coins being sold um
and so i think this is a better
indicator as to
like the the um behavior of selling from
from different cohorts by age
when you have really low volume like
this i hope that made sense no that was
super wordy
so anyway this has been trending down
and something that you know we've been
watching for a while but it's just
showing
the selling is coming from majority new
market participants
and you know we're seeing that that
aggressive accumulation from strong
hands
while you know coinciding um most of the
selling coming from
you know new mark participants aka
weekends
got it and then what about miners it
seems like the miners are
kind of continuing to not sell and
accumulate is that true
yeah absolutely so um looking at this
two different ways
you actually could look at it three
different ways but in the newsletter i
put in the the
transfer volume from miners exchanges so
this is just looking at the raw
um inflows and outflows to exchanges and
so you see this has been in the
downtrend since
kind of mid mid february but we had a
big spike around when we had the whole
china migration
um you know when when miners were moving
out of china um and had to liquidate
some of their bitcoin to to
move um but that's gone back into a
downtrend after that
um and then another way to look at this
is just the minor net position change
so there's the minor net balance um and
then there's also the net position
change so the minor balance is
is good if you're trying to watch like
intraday things but
if you're really trying to identify
trend i think that the net position
changes is a lot more valuable because
if you're seeing a clear trend on
something that that is looking at
you know a 30-day difference of
something it's it's
uh in my opinion a much clearer um
signal
of of a kind of broader trend rather
than just like
looking you know on every day at oh you
know
minor balance went up today minor
balance went down a little bit tomorrow
like it could get super noisy and just
kind of like
it it's just too much to you know i'd
rather just look at what what's what's
the broader trend you know the
solidified trend
you know over a 30-day basis so i think
like that minor net position change is
is the most valuable in terms of like
looking at that trend but
yeah for sure miners have been
accumulating um you know especially over
the last two weeks
all right and then utxo bring us home
with this last one what uh what are you
seeing in the utxo you love utxo
yeah i love this chart because it's
basically like a uh
a volume profile of bitcoin um and so
you know it's it's showing how many you
know how many bitcoins how much of the
supply has moved at different price
levels
um and so what you see is we just have
like this massive zone of volume between
30k 40k especially between like 30k and
35k
and so when we went down below 30 we
were kind of like looking over into the
abyss where we really didn't have any
support until like 26k
or 22k um but you know it looked like
we got pushed right back up into there
and so now we're kind of sitting back in
the middle of this range
uh but one interesting thing um the the
31
uh seven that that level has the highest
level of uh
of money bitcoin's money supply that's
moved at
at that since uh 10 300. so you have
this huge kind of base of capital here
building up and uh
i you know if we were to have some kind
of bull run continuation i would be
eyeing this level for some kind of like
macro support level in the future but
uh yeah this is this is um
you know the largest zone of support
that we've seen since you know
like 6k to 10k
so all right just as a kind of summary
how are you feeling right now like in
terms of what we're seeing
um bullish bearish still sideways kind
of cautiously optimistic
how would you categorize it sure um so
i i think in the short term right you
you know we can be subject to perhaps
you know a bunch of
leveraged traders hop in all of a sudden
decide to go leverage along and that's
gonna
of course you know incentivized price
they kind of get pushed down in the
short term so
you know it could get a little noisy in
the next couple days perhaps but
you know i suspect over the next couple
weeks we're gonna start to see a move up
um you know the the accumulation trends
that we've been following for over a
month now
uh i think are finally starting to get
priced in a bit you know it didn't seem
like it would
you know it was going to happen for a
while but yeah
i think over the next few weeks you'll
start to see that kind of get reflected
in the price especially once volume
returns
um just and i'd say that just because
watching volatility
um you know some of the charts that we
had mentioned earlier
uh you know we're we're sitting right on
this on the breakout of
you know this big move and and uh you
know looking at
where that you know if i had to you know
guess where that was going to go based
off of on chain you know showing seeing
that accumulation
to me is is plenty that that move is
going to be awkward so
um you know that that volatility break
is going to come out in the next couple
weeks and that's why i say that so
yeah i'll be i'll be watching closely
man
what uh what do you think is uh the most
likely scenario through the end of the
year
yeah it's a it's an interesting question
um
you know i think it all depends on like
what you see from the institutionals and
you know if you start to get a bunch of
announcements and i don't know like some
etf news then it could get pretty crazy
um i i personally think that we kind of
top out in in early mid 2022
um i've seen it as far as like the
length of the cycles the idea of like
this lengthening cycle thesis i
i i kind of agree with that um so i i
wouldn't be surprised if
you know like we didn't ex if we
extended out to
you know um spring to to summer 2022
uh for some kind of like you know big um
you know final move up perhaps uh but
for now
i'm just i'm just watching to see you
know in the short term if we can break
the 200a because i think that's that's
kind of like a key level that
you know traders in general or investors
in general watch
um to determine if an asset is kind of
in a bold bear
market right um so watching that level
and then if we can break all-time highs
um you know i think we'll we'll see a
pretty aggressive move upwards but
i think in terms of like the remainder
of the year a lot of that depends
on well the macro too obviously but just
from like a pure
internal bitcoin standpoint um i think
what you kind of see from the
institutional adoption side
what about you what do you think i think
that uh
there's a lot of bears sentiment and
bitcoins lulling people to sleep but uh
i'm not sleeping i uh i remain convicted
on the
on the long term so good luck to
everyone out there
yeah i got into bitcoin in summer last
year and
and so i remember when we were sitting
at like the
mid mid 9k like we were sitting at like
92 to 9 800 and we were just like
chopping and chopping and chopping and i
was like this thing never moves
like what is everybody talking about
bitcoins exciting and stuff like this
thing is just
sideways forever and then all of a
sudden i remember boom
it broke through 10k and that was it and
a very similar thing with 20k
you know we were just sideways sideways
sideways and you know the high
19 thousands and then i remember one day
i woke up this mo
woke up one morning and and we'd broken
out to like
22k or something and it's like bitcoin
moves in like a very small portion of
time
and so like being being out of them
that's why i always like i i'm always i
think gonna have
you know a a large portion of my
holdings just in
you know just in cold storage because
with bitcoin like the real risk is
one day waking up and you know all of a
sudden prices driven up on some news or
whatever it may be but like you know
most of the moves i've seen some
statistics on it but i don't know it off
the top of my head most of the moves
come in a very small portion of the time
that bitcoin trades so
that that has always been true and i
think uh it's gonna be no different here
so
pretty uh pretty nuts um all right where
can we send people to uh follow you on
twitter or uh or follow the uh the
newsletter
yeah sure i'm on twitter at uh w
clementi iii
and then my newsletter is uh btc by wc3
all right my friend we will uh we will
do this again next week but you're doing
a great job
keep it up i think a lot of people are
counting on you to keep them informed so
let's uh let's talk again at the end of
next week
sure thanks a lot paul take it easy